i did relate to that part but it was it
was different
imagine living in a world where lady
gaga wasn't the lead in a star is born
wild right well it was almost a reality
there are tons of movies and tv series
in hollywood that were one casting
choice away from looking
completely different luckily actors like
jennifer lawrence and robert pattinson
preserved
and were able to fight their way up to
the top and prove
everyone wrong you'll never be able to
look at some of these actors the same
way
again when you find out who almost
replaced them
and james cameron started this rumor
somehow that i got the role
lady gaga not being bradley cooper's
duet partner in shallow
unimaginable to us but it was the route
warner brothers originally wanted to
take the movie in
the studio just didn't think she was the
right fit for the role
and were a little skeptical about her
lack of acting experience
but bradley cooper wasn't having it he
knew she was the perfect ally
bradley even called her plutonium we're
guessing he meant
along the lines of radioactive that's
why he teamed up with gaga
and the two worked together on
perfecting their screen tests in order
to prove them wrong
and that was actually one of the first
things when i was trying to pitch this
movie to warner brothers i showed them
that video
no one told lisa kudrow her audition was
gonna be
this way she also never knew how much
harder she had to fight for her role as
phoebe on friends compared to her fellow
castmates
you can see the exact moment she
realized on a friend's reunion
check it out you had to audition for
china audition but
not audition but i did according to the
actress
on top of her first audition she
auditioned for director james burrows
six more times before they finally
agreed on casting her
the rest of the cast never even had to
audition for the director at all
five out of six of the friends are in
and i went
oh my god they didn't ask me it's a good
thing they did hire her
not only is she iconic but she went on
to be nominated for
six emmy awards team jacob would have
looked
a lot different if taylor lautner didn't
give everything he had to keep his role
as jacob black
while his role as jacob in twilight was
secured the producers
just weren't convinced he'd be able to
transform into the
bulked-up jacob they needed in the next
four films
there were even talks of recasting him
with michael copen
however taylor lautner took on the
challenge hit the gym and proved them
all wrong then you should be team jacob
come come to the dark side
lily reinhardt just wouldn't take no for
an answer when it came to her audition
for betty on riverdale
she's admitted that she was going
through a rough patch on her mental
health journey when she auditioned for
the role and was trying to turn her life
around
she sent in multiple self-recorded tapes
for the part and was rejected
each and every time she just couldn't
get it right but lily finally said
enough was enough and auditioned in
person she finally
got the part brb we're just realizing
this
probably would have meant lily and cole
sprouse never
meeting well they compare themselves to
romeo and juliet a couple times
crazy rich asians is a cinematic
masterpiece there's no denying it
but they were one casting decision away
from possibly not having a hit movie
constance wu had to fight to be able to
get the role of rachel
she wasn't able to make the projected
filming dates of the movie because she
was still on a series
fresh off the boat constance wasn't
giving up that easily though
she sent a very detailed and strongly
worded email about how much the role
meant to her
guess what it worked i guess it was a
really good email
the director switched around the dates
and constance was able to finish filming
fresh off the boat
before heading over to the crazy rich
asian set this movie means so much to so
many and i want people to enjoy whoa
twilight almost looked even more
different than we thought
not only was taylor almost booted but
robert pattinson was
this close to not playing edward cullen
twice
first stephanie meyer was convinced
henry cavill was the one for edward
she wanted me to play the role but
it wasn't up to her but it turned out he
was a little too old for the role by the
time
filming rolled around then when our pats
didn't land the role he was almost fired
for how
determined he was to make edward more
broody instead of happy
sorry for anything today
in order to appease the director and
producers he had to make a huge effort
to reverse how he took on the role
or he would have been fired just take a
listen to his recount of the situation
you have to do the opposite of what
you're doing now you're gonna get fired
today reese witherspoon's journey to
landing the part of
l woods in legally blonde was rough to
say the least
after her first audition they basically
told her that she wasn't
provocative enough to play the role and
she was of course discouraged
in order to impress them her agents told
her she had to change up her look for
her second audition
so that's what she did but it was at the
expense of being asked
some pretty inappropriate questions i
remember a room full of men were asking
me
questions about being a co-ed and being
in a sorority
rhys says when she looks back she can't
believe that even happened
as women you're usually the only woman
on a set we still gush at the sight of
kate winslet and leonardo dicaprio
but their iconic friendship might not
have been as strong as it is if kate
hadn't landed her role as rose in
titanic
luckily kate fought tooth and nails to
be considered movie runners had been
looking at gwyneth paltrow to take on
the role
but kate managed to get a hold of
director james cameron and told him
straight up that she was the only
perfect option for the role
iconic there's something very special
about that
and and so unexpected although jennifer
lawrence had
already proved her impeccable acting
skills as katniss in hunger games
producers just weren't sold on her
playing tiffany in silver linings
playbook
their excuse she was just too young
in fact they even had their eye on anne
hathaway taking on the part instead
but j law being jayla made sure she did
all she could to prep for her audition
and
absolutely blew them away unsurprising
considering the part literally landed
her
an academy award i would have never been
able to do that if i wasn't
scared out of my mind silver lining's
playbook wasn't the first time jennifer
lawrence had to work for a job her
breakout role in winter's bone wasn't
the easiest path into hollywood
producers didn't want to cast her
because she was too pretty
some could say i was too attractive for
the part i didn't look
right but she wasn't having it she flew
down to new york in order to audition in
person
looking a little less presentable red
eye
not showering no makeup eventually they
went
oh she's right she's not cute lo and
behold
it worked how can i win and i i just won
cheers blake lively was just a little
too
sunny california for the producers of
gossip girl she just wasn't giving off
the upper east side vibes that they
needed during her first audition
instead they wanted to cast rumor willis
i just saw him like crying he was like
you made me cry and it was just so
sweet but blake lively took their
feedback and went in for a more
sophisticated look
straight hair and all the production
team was swayed and we got
the iconic character that is serena
vanderwoodson
fun fact jennifer lawrence also tried
out for the same role before she got big
in hollywood
xoxo gossip girl i moved here to new
york to shoot
a gossip girl and now we're done we
can't imagine anyone
playing drax other than dave bautista
it's not
just an option but the directors of
guardians of the galaxy couldn't always
see that
they didn't even want to give him the
opportunity to audition because of his
pro wrestler status
to make it worse his agent let him know
before the audition how hard it was to
get him there
because of their hesitancy but dave took
acting lessons and researched his
characters and was thankfully able to
sway the casting directors
in his direction and we'll be forever
grateful they did
disney to say we made a mistake and
we're gonna you know we're gonna make
this wrong
right thinking about some of these
iconic roles being played by other
actors is making our heads spin
imagine how different some of these
films and tv shows would have turned out
without them
taylor lautner not playing jacob as if
although some of these actors had to
fight tooth and nail to get their roles
we wouldn't have it any other way which
production do you think
would be the most changed without the
actors we know and love